visto desde el aire Es un edificio casi
como cualquier otro pero aquí las obras
llevan un año y medio paradas es una
obra abandonada y es su casa
ahogado por sus deudas you want Fu se
trasladó aquí hace tres meses
de momento la hora no está terminada
mira todavía hay herramientas masillas
tablas
todo se ha dejado como está e incluso
hay algo dentro de los apartamentos
no tiene dónde ir como todos los
propietarios de este edificio compró
sobre plano a un promotor al borde de la
quiebra estas unidades debían entregarse
en junio de 2021
aquí es donde vivo ahora
40 metros cuadrados por 45.000 euros
condiciones de vida deplorables se las
arregla con otros propietarios
uno de mis vecinos es electricista Así
que se las arregló para hacer las
conexiones para que tengamos energía en
la habitación
Pero solo para tener luz y cargar
nuestros teléfonos móviles u otros
dispositivos
tampoco hay agua filtrada solo depósitos
de agua de lluvia en varias ocasiones el
promotor prometió reanudar las obras
pero las promesas no se cumplieron la
empresa no tenía los fondos necesarios
you ya no tiene fuerzas para luchar
cuando defendimos nuestros derechos
fuimos reprimidos varias veces por la
policía
no entiendo por qué se me considero un
mal ciudadano solo por haber comprado un
piso sin terminar qué puedo decir solo
puedo esperar
tres meses antes los propietarios
presionaron el promotor ocupan toda la
planta baja cuentan su lucha en las
redes sociales una movilización poco
frecuente en China pero no dura algunos
incluso son detenidos por la policía en
la actualidad Solo queda Lee de 24 años
irónicamente es un antiguo agente
inmobiliario ahora está desempleado
como necesito dinero para vivir y para
pagar mi préstamo aprendí a vender estas
parrillas en la calle
Li solo gana unos 10 euros al día se
pregunta Cuándo tendrá su piso
pueden pasar otros 8 incluso 10 años
algunos edificios no se han entregado ni
siquiera después de 10 años
estos esqueletos de cemento forman parte
del paisaje de China el 40% de los
compradores están esperando las llaves
de sus casas porque en todo el país una
treintena de promotores se hunden bajo
cientos de miles de millones de euros de
deuda y no pueden completar sus
proyectos el enfado de los propietarios
se puede escuchar Incluso en la calle
casi un millón de ellos se niegan a
pagar sus préstamos hasta que les
entreguen sus pisos estas imágenes son
rápidamente censuradas en las redes
sociales para este economista la
magnitud del movimiento alarma a las
autoridades
creo que el gobierno probablemente
intervendrá como prestamista de última
instancia
para asegurarse de que los proyectos se
completan
porque el verdadero problema para el
gobierno es la credibilidad y la
confianza de los compradores e
inversores
la crisis también afecta a los
productores de acero y cemento y a todas
las pequeñas empresas de construcción
las víctimas colaterales son los
trabajadores al pie de las torres han
abandonado los cuarteles este maestro de
obras ha visto a todos sus empleados no
hay más dinero no recibimos Nada aquí
los trabajadores han trabajado durante
cuatro o cinco meses pero han cobrado
menos de 300 euros como pueden
sobrevivir
su empresa le deja este insalubre
prefabricado para vivir no hay salario
ni apoyo financiero francamente estamos
cansados de pedir ayuda al gobierno ya
hemos pedido ayuda a los departamentos
de trabajo y construcción pero no se ha
hecho nada
medio el gobierno sí anunció ayudas más
de 150 mil millones de euros en
préstamos para aliviar a los promotores
no es seguro que esto sea suficiente
para salvar el sector inmobiliario un
antiguo motor de crecimiento que se ha
convertido en un lastre para la economía
China